rather than shy away from a challenge
the filmmakers in these next categories
have embraced it presenting stories in a
limited time frame but these limits had
no effect on the types of stories they
could tell or the depths they could
explore
here are the nominees for best
documentary short film
the elephant Whispers Carnegie Gonzalez
and gunit Monga
[Applause]
Paula evgenya or bugayva and Maxim
arbugayov
how do you measure a year Jay rosenblatt
imagine
[Applause]
[Music]
the Martha Mitchell effect
andovergae and Beth levison
stranger at the gate Joshua safetel and
Colonel Jones
[Applause]
and the and the Oscar goes to
the elephant Whispers Gonzalez
Monga was amongst the first producers
from India to be inducted into the
academy kartiki Gonzalez's work travels
extensively to capture visuals that will
raise awareness about cultures animals
and the environment
[Music]
I stand here today to speak for the
sacred bond between us and our natural
world for the respect of indigenous
communities and empathy towards other
living beings we share our space with
and finally for coexistence thank you to
the academy for recognizing our film
highlighting indigenous people and
animals to Netflix for believing in the
power of this film to Bowman belly and
for sharing their sacred tribal wisdom
to guneet my producer and secure to
Douglas blush my mentor and my entire
team and finally to my mother father and
sister who are up there somewhere and
you are the Center of My Universe to my
motherland India
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you